again I run into him a couple times sake
a day like this nice sort of like
details but it was painful it's messy
it's weird at shitty but it's also like
we were done we were done and we signed
a piece of paper and we walked out of
the office because we didn't go to a
lawyer or anything we just feel like
signed paperwork and we walked out and
he walked to his Aston Martin and I
walked to my knees let me drive him out
here
he went that way and I went to my little
missin and he goes see ya and then we
just drove off and there was no like
that's my fork yes again there was no no
no I just because I was done and he was
done and then there's no I don't need
anything from you like I don't want any
we both work we both make money it's
good so I in my case I must say I had an
easy divorce but that's I see people go
through traumatic and you know a
few things were written for the three
people that know who we are but like and
again I'll just give a like no I
don't know if there's other things that
upset me and there's other things you
think there's so many other things
there's many unexpected things that
happen lies lies hurt cheating liar
cheating hurts did those are painful
things but you're never cheated in my
life you've never cheated in your life
never change I commend you you know what
knock on wood yeah I mean not knock on
wood but I haven't either I was really
not kind of what I hope I don't know I
haven't either yeah that's one thing I
can't do so that's like when I am in a
relationship when I say I love you this
is us not the NBC series but like this
is us yeah then that's it I I like to
hear that from you know well it's
important I've said that before Ryan are
you that guy - yeah yeah